Hey everybody, it's Charlie.
Oh my God we just I like the most amazing
four hours of TV crossovers that we've ever
seen in the DC universe before this is going
to be my legends video.
Just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet and there is a new round of the flash
ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to turn alerts on we have the finales coming
next week but let's talk about the crazy crossover
we learn about how Supergirl is going to come
back in the back half of the season for another
flash crossover, so I'll try to explain all
that stuff and then him to do a separate video
tomorrow what I think they're going to do
next year for the big four way crossover because
even though arrow is in its fifth season.
They even had a reference about how this all
started with us that was with that line between
Sara and Oliver was in a double meaning it
all started with us on the boat, but it also
started with the arrow TV show like the big
arrow verse will try to explain all that is.
I work through Easter eggs in top 10, but
here we go number 10 Oliver asks Kara to sit
this one out because she's an unknown quantity
and he feels like he can't trust her.
I know it felt like he was being a super dicta
her any kind of was like he was keeping her
at arms length, just because he only has like
so much weirdness that he can process you
can also think of it is him being kind of
like a battle commander like you need to fully
understand and trust all the people on your
team and he just felt like he couldn't trust
car yet because he didn't know her that well
that all changed by the end of the episode
so they also kind of did the same thing with
Cisco and Barry, I know a lot of you are like
why is Cisco being such a dicta Barry number
nine.
Cisco finally comes around on Barry after
he realizes that he also derp's in the past,
making the future invasion that much worse.
So number eight Cisco Felicity and part of
the legends go back into the past to capture
dominator and find out what the hell is going
on so they go back to that viral footage from
1951.
We get to see Citizen steel in his comic book
costume for the first time and he would just
barbecues one of the dominators in the nuts
is pretty hilarious.
But then they get taken in and it turns into
this big X-Files storyline, so number seven
WTF they have their own version of the smoking
man.
So the minute he showed up in the past I knew
that he was the same old man in the future
that had been there when the first president
was taken.
So was like okay they're doing a X-Files thing
where you have an evil part of the government
the tries to collude with the dominators make
a deal for their survival.
It's right out of classic X-Files there was
this big storyline during X-Files where aliens
bad aliens were invading in a group of humans
including the smoking man colluded with them
in order to ensure their survival.
So like this is their version of that smoking
man who is now being sent to Antarctica, but
because Cisco Felicity are there this whole
time the just all kinds of movie references
being dropped.
So the hypnotic supersonic funky fresh is
a Sierra song Felicity throws up twice and
just starts making up words because she can't
speak right one of the gibberish phrases that
she speaks is right out of a Star Trek the
next generation episode.
She says Darmok and Jalad at Tanagra that's
right out of an episode where Captain Picard
has to understand this alien is speaking some
different language and he just keep saying
that phrase over and over.
They dropped the Princess bride reference
Cisco drops a Spielberg reference which is
war of the worlds then when they figure out
the need to say them he drops a stranger thing
shoutout men in black, set your phasers the
stun which is obviously Star Trek, so they
were just pages and pages of Cisco in Felicity
movie references number six Martin Stein's
ministry daughter turns out she's like the
super engineer just like Ray Palmer knows
all about nanotechnology, but she turns into
one of the emotional foundations of the story
for firestorm early on just the look on Caitlin's
face when she figured out that Martin Stein
was going to a race her after they were done
with all this like it is gonna go back and
just wink her out of existence, but obviously
he comes full circle and he asks Jack's to
keep the secret from the team.
So just remember now that Martin Stein has
a big secret from the rest of the team, but
they always say that like the best characters
have a secret that nobody else knows about
but the problem with firestorm is that they
share mine.
So there are no secrets between Jackson Martin
Stein.
So that's why he had to make that deal with
Jax at the end number five they learned in
present day that the dominators are after
Barry because of flashpoint.
They had come in the past, to 1951.
Because they detected metahuman's and just
wanted to see what was up.
They knew about the JSA.
So in the future when they detected the changes
in the timeline because of flashpoint.
That's when they came back.
So Barry has to sacrifice himself for the
kill all metahuman's and just because the
bond they're using is so big deal kill a bunch
of regular people to, so Barry Allen just
always gets the shaft anytime the universe
is on the line crisis on infinite earths during
flash point he has to let the reverse flash
go back and kill his mother again like he
has to willingly let him kill his mother so
was cool as it would be to have the powers
of the flash the more powerful you get in
the comics the bigger sacrifices you're asked
to make, but number for Cisco back in the
present uses the transponder he stole off
the alien ship to vibe him and citizen steel
up and find out what's going on.
So is nice is the dominator is his like you
we can't give you Barry were totally gonna
take them were totally gonna blow Pires and
even complement Cisco on being a metahuman
right before he tells him about the bond is
going to kill all metahuman's.
So even with all the crazy vibe stuff that
Cisco did in the episode he still not wearing
the comic book costume in present day he doesn't
quite have the goblets on all the time that
will probably change in the back half of the
season I'm busy but season for he'll at least
start were in the costume and hopefully they
can find a way for killer Frost to use her
powers to but we can talk about that when
I post my flash video next week.
But number three Barry tries to give them
the speech about how is gonna sacrifice himself,
the team will let him is this big rally moment
you know you're part of the crew we roll out
together so they have their bid rollout where
they all stand in formation in number two
they have their Captain America Civil War
airport battle scene just the big action set
piece Oliver falls off the building.
Kara saves them and then car and Barry have
to run all over the world at superspeed race
around the world and try to attach all the
devices to the dominators they beat them off
then they get the congratulations from the
new president who tells them that is still
has to be secret.
But there.
This extra long establishing shot of the Hall
of Justice, just to let you know that this
is going to continue to be a big thing in
number one all the after party just like everybody
saying their goodbyes.
Cisco gives Kara the device that will allow
her to open breaches so that she can come
back for crossovers anytime she wants.
She can call them anytime she wants so very
clearly this is what they're going to use
to get her back on the flash for the second
crossover in the back half of the season so
if you didn't know there's gonna be a Supergirl
crossover with the flash just with the flash
now with the other TV shows in the second
half of the season going to be like their
musical episode.
We don't know a whole lot about it now like
what.
The twist is going to be why it's gonna be
a musical so that's a long ways off.
Don't worry about it now.
It just that they have an easy way to get
car on for crossovers now but this it only
works for one person Ray Palmer has that really
funny moment with car were Brandon Ralph is
like hey she looks kind like my cousin just
a nice wink at the fact that he used to be
Superman I been waiting for them to do that
they haven't done that many Superman Brandon
Routh jokes.
But one of my favorite like deep meaning lines
was that Sara Oliver moment were she's like
this all started with us.
So like is that you know double meaning it
all started on the boat the Queen's gambit
with all this craziness, but the arrow verse
the big crossover just all the stuff that's
happening now started with them Oliver makes
a nice reference to being in the dreamland
during the Arrow hundred episode.
I don't need to wonder what my life would've
been like.
They actually gave us that gift and I like
my life the way it is now it's better complicated,
which is kind of the speech that he had with
Barry.
When they have drinks like they did after
the first arrow flash crossover where they
have like the rocky team up match like who
would win in the fight like they're sitting
there drinking who would win the fight like
this 11 that drunk guy, comic book argument
if you like was a great episode.
It was nice bookend to the crossover the episode
itself, but the crossover, the four night
crossover or three night crossover have you
want to think about it was a really good couple
hours of television that felt like a movie.
But the impressive thing is that they were
able to do it on a TV budget and it especially
a CW budget which is in a major network, so
they don't have major network money let me
know what was your favorite moment from this
episode what was your favorite crossover moment
I did like all the funny weird moments, but
deftly like their big comic book rollout was
probably my favorite, at least from this episode
now we gotta talk about what we want them
to do next year with the crossover, all talk
about that in a separate video specific storylines
I want them to do.
But Manhunters or a giant Legion of doom team
up.
It just has to be a threat that's big enough
to merit all of the supers like you don't
need Supergirl to fight Damien Darhk or Malcolm
Merlin.
You need Supergirl to fight somebody from
outer space like giant big super strong person
but like I said these big team ups drive rating
so hard-core arrow like doubled its ratings
is up 77% across the board for the entire
season in that just one example, so I think
what they'll try to do is that is arrow slowly
goes off the air so try to do another big
team up show like teen Titans.
That's why you been hearing a lot of live-action
teen Titans talk lately because they already
have most of those characters on all these
for shows.
So if one of them goes off the air they can
just bring the others onto the other shows.
And once they have enough in was that the
space and the schedule the money to do it
he does do a full-blown teen Titans show.
So I will do like a teen Titans video.
The next week or two and I know a lot of you
been asking about young justice stuff but
I'll say congratulations to the winner of
this round of the giveaway, Kevin Lopez you
win one of the flash rings please private
message me on the back and my channel so I
can get your contact details.
There is a new round that's already going
right now so I'll announce the winner for
that The next time I post a DC video.
so tomorrow there's a whole bunch of stuff
happening.
There's a rumor that there's going to be a
Spider-Man homecoming trailer if there is
all totally do a video for that I've also
got Rick and Morty the video for next year's
crossover.
So there will be a whole bunch of stuff posting
in the next couple of days while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here for
that big flash trailer for next week and you
can click here for all the other crossover
videos thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys tonight!